Today we'll learn about water pollution.
Clean water is mandatory for life.
When water gets polluted, it becomes unhealthy for everyone.
Water pollution has become an increasing problem on our Earth,...
...which is affecting human and animal lives.
Water pollution occurs when chemicals, waste or other particles...
...cause a body of water to become harmful to everybody.
Let's see the causes of water pollution.
Natural causes.
Sometimes volcanoes, animal waste, algae, and silt from floods cause water pollution.
Human causes.
Some human causes for water pollution are sewage, fertilizers and pesticides from farms,...
...wastes from factories and construction sites.
Acid rain.
Acid rain can turn lakes acidic and it kills fish and other animals.
Oil spillage.
Oil spills generally happen in the ocean...
...and cause many devastating effects to animals, plants and humans.
Let's see some effects of water pollution.
Death of aquatic animals.
It kills organisms like fish, crabs, birds and dolphins...
...that depend on these water bodies.
Disruption of food chains.
Pollutants are eaten by small animals.
These animals are consumed by fish and others...
...and the food chain continues to be disrupted at all the levels.
Diseases.
Drinking polluted water can cause serious health problems.
Let's see some steps to control water pollution.
Always look for the correct waste bin for throwing waste.
Save water, close the tap when not in use.
Do not throw waste chemicals, oils and medicines in the sink drain.
Do not overuse pesticides and fertilizers.
Try planting more and more trees.
Now you know a lot about water pollution.